ramsay network this is the ramsay show
where we help you get control of your
money get ahead in your career and get
on the path to living well i'm george
campbell your host joined today by
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author host of the rachel cruz show
a mother a daughter a friend to all
that's her
we are excited to take your call so give
us one triple eight eight two five five
two two five let us help you take the
right next step maybe you're at a
crossroads you need some inspiration
some motivation
uh you're stressed out about inflation
we can help we can help we're blessed to
be a blessing so let's do that this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five jordan kicks us off in st louis
missouri jordan welcome to the show i
don't have the show here let me flip
back there we go jordan are you with us
yes yes thank you for taking my call yes
how can rachel and i help
hey just wondering if you guys had any
tips on
staying forward thinking in terms of
saving and doing everything
you know the way i should do it but also
being able to be present and enjoy the
moment
interesting so what's the question
what's the pain point there are you
you're budgeting right now currently
and you feel like you're not able to
enjoy it
well not necessarily it's just i feel
like you know saving and everything is
much more geared towards the future um
but i don't want to stay i want to be
able to enjoy the moment
and enjoy the present
but also be able to
um
secure the future
so that can be reflected in your budget
do you have things in your budget that
involve spending and vacations and
buying things that you want to buy
so i think it's more of just a general
mindset thing than
like budget specific
so it's like it's it's hard for me to
shift gears from like future future
future to enjoy the present
yeah and i think that there's a time and
a place for all that
that thinking and and dreaming i mean i
i'm probably more like you jordan i
probably enjoy the present easier than i
do thinking about the future so
i just know with my personality then i'm
like okay i have to set time
to make sure that i'm looking at future
goals but i don't do that every day i
mean winston and i my husband and i will
you know we have we call it dream
dinners i don't know how cheesy that is
might be a little cheesy but we'll just
go to dinner and be like okay if money
wasn't an option what would we do in
like some dinners we like take the
conversation down to
what if we lived in montana on a ranch
and we're like off the grid like it's
that to
buying a new car i mean whatever it is
but it's like you just let yourself
dream and then out of that you really
see okay where do i want my future to go
and then yeah then you kind of set money
aside to get there and to hit that goal
but but i'm not sitting there every day
thinking oh what am i going to be when
i'm 50 oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh dude i'm
saying so i i feel like i do enjoy the
moment while having goals for the future
uh but i think there's a level of
probably contentment jordan too of the
present of just being excited and happy
where you are
and then when the time comes that you
carve out specific intentional time to
really think about the future
then you're able to be in that mindset
but i think you can turn that mindset
off and you don't have to live in that
in a daily basis does that make sense
does that
help yeah absolutely i mean that's
that's great advice i do think i kind of
get stuck in that mindset sometimes and
it
produces a lot of anxiety so i
appreciate that what helped me jordan
was having a good healthy mix of
short-term and long-term goals so an
example me and my wife who want to go to
europe later this year that's a
short-term goal we want to save up for
we also know we want to save up to buy a
upgraded house later down the road that
could be a few years from now but we
also have things that are happening this
weekend that are in the budget that
we're saving up for and so i think
having that mix makes you feel like i'm
not just thinking about the future yeah
and it helps when you're doing the thing
for the weekend that you're present in
the moment in the weekend and you're
like hey we planned on going out to a
nice dinner with friends so when you're
enjoying your nice dinner
you actually enjoy the dinner and
thinking about the moment you're not
thinking oh gosh i gotta fund my 401k to
make sure i have this amount of money
you know what i mean don't let yourself
go there because i do think jordan to
your point that can be unhealthy and it
steals
the joy of the moment that you're in if
you're constantly just thinking about
the future and the past like i know
people that live in the past oh yeah and
it's the either the regret or the oh
those were great years if we could just
go right and there's a time and a place
to go back but i think that there's a
healthy mentality to be in the present
and to enjoy it so i think you're on the
right track jordan um i think it's a
great question are you married jordan
uh no i'm not i'm single i'm 28 years
old okay what i would do if i'm if i'm
in your shoes i'm gonna find some
friends that i think are wise and that i
want to hang out with and go kind of
dream a little bit with them and use
them as accountability and use them as
kind of that
bounce bouncing launch pad to go hey
let's have some fun i want to budget for
some things in the short term i want to
budget for some things in the long term
maybe they'll give you some ideas of
what that could look like
yeah
all right i hope that helps thanks
jordan appreciate the call man you know
it would be an interesting i'm just
doing this on the fly if it works it
works it's friday it's all live okay if
you there are single people out there
call in
because i do want to have a discussion
about this quote-unquote like
accountability partner so i say that
because we talk about that a lot at
ramsey
i kind of hate that word can i say that
to you yeah accountability feels icky i
agree it feels like old youth group of
like i don't know i don't know so find a
friend that you like
and the idea then the reason we say this
is because you don't need to do life
alone and when you're single
you know it's isolating all of your
decisions are up to you everything from
buying groceries to making sure the
oil's fixed in the car
if you have a car that has oil fell a
tesla owner there wow right there don't
leave me hanging oh i'm sorry
but what i'm saying is like you're not
sorry george
the
the
decision making you're you're making it
in a vacuum in so many areas of life so
having a person that walks beside you
um to bounce those especially those big
decisions with yeah is really important
when you're starting out budgeting
having someone that's wise with money to
be like hey i just want you to look at
this and make sure i'm not missing
anything crazy and it's a very organic
natural conversation i feel like
sometimes it can sound so wrong walk up
to someone go will you be my
accountability partner and you see my
budget every single month can we meet on
the 15th at 3 o'clock
but but i do if you're single out there
and you have this person in your life
and it's working well i want you to call
in because i want to talk about it i
think there's a really
great way to do it
um that is
very helpful
and is possible but it's not um overly
form you know that it's not just like
awkward or something wow well there it
is rachel just opened up a singles theme
hour so give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
talk about this is good because two i'm
gonna keep adding on here because i got
married young so winston is all i mean
i've had a husband for
the whole basically my whole adult life
yeah
so when i talk about it i know friends
that have done it and you know and i
have a friend and she's great at having
someone in her corner um but i always
like to hear real life how this works
for people day in and day out and what
it really looks like tactically so but
for you
did you ever have a good friend that
that was at before oh yeah because
there's there's friends that have been
mentors to me that i look up to a lot of
people really show them your budget yeah
we talk to you know the ins and outs of
money especially in a place like this at
ramsey i know it's very normal for us to
talk about money and so it's it's fun
it's almost fun it's like a sport to us
like what's in your budget this month
how you saving up for that how'd you do
that you know we kind of it's like
inside baseball here at ramsey but it is
true when you get outside of the ramsey
bubble you're like oh people don't talk
about money right right it's unless
they're making fun of how you know
screwed they are with their student
loans and
you know car payments so give us a call
aaa
825-5225 whether you're single or not
but rachel wants to talk to the single
folks so give us a call we'll be back
with you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print podcast joined
today by rachel cruz and we are taking
your calls the number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five rachel and i just got
back from orlando with the gang dave ken
john deloney we were all out there doing
a building wealth live event in orlando
and it was amazing we had what three
thousand people there yeah they were
pumped up ready to go and
really the takeaway from this event is
it is still possible to build wealth in
2022. it's possible and we're going to
show you how to do it in a wise way
because there's a lot of
messages out there and tactics and ways
to do it that sounds really shiny and
exciting and fun and easy
and we kind of debunk
a lot of that sadly because a lot of
myths out there there's a lot of myths
that end up it sounds good in the short
term if you watch the news you're like
well there's no way rachel the recession
is here i mean inflation just keeps
going the housing market the car market
nobody can build wealth we can't even
survive yes and it is a difficult time
right now so
saying okay what are these issues and we
talk about that at a round table all of
us
um and kind of dive into hey here are
the things going on here are the ways to
combat it and here's the right way and
the smart and wise way over time to win
with money and build wealth so yeah it's
been it's been such a fun event we did
vegas two weeks ago orlando last night
and we hit the road for the fall yes so
uh thank you orlando for coming out you
guys were amazing people drove flew from
all over the country to be there we were
signing books taking photos to the wee
hours of the night loved hearing their
stories talking with financial peace
university coordinators pastors from the
area it was incredible so our spring
tours wrapped up but we are not done yet
building wealth live is coming to a few
cities across the country this fall and
we want everyone to hear how to build
wealth the right way so if you are near
these areas or can make it to these
areas we'd love to see you phoenix
september 13th sacramento on november
1st minneapolis on november 10th in san
antonio on november 15th tickets start
at just 25 bucks or you can get a four
pack of tickets starting at just 60 to
60 dollars so bring your friends it's
going to be amazing ramsay solutions.com
events
is the place to go to get your tickets
all right rachel so you know we like to
we like to browse social media every now
and then and i got this video from a
friend the other day that was
fascinating and it's all about the newer
generations the younger generations gen
z and the relationship to cash now we
say cash is king around here but there's
a new slogan for gen z cash is free
[Music]
i know it sounds like an oxymoron so
we're gonna play the video and uh we'll
get your reaction okay
the other day i was out and i made a
purchase at a store
and the
gen z person who was checking me out
said that'll be 18 something and i
pulled out of my purse at 20 and i gave
her the 20. and i said i just have cash
and she said oh wow that's like it's
then it's like free
and i said oh what do you mean and she
said well if you pay with cash it's free
and i said
i don't know what you mean
and she said well like if you have a
five dollar bill and you buy a coffee
for 4.98 it's like a free coffee it's
like it doesn't count cashes it doesn't
count it's not real money
and
i was very so
i came home and both of my kids are gen
z and i asked them both
what was she talking about and my
daughter who is 18 said yeah cash
doesn't count if you have cash it
doesn't count it's not like it's real
money the real money is what's in your
debit
on your debit card
is this true
is this true i love this love her energy
there she's just as confused as all of
us that is so funny it raises an
interesting question okay
so here's my okay here reminds me my
like knee-jerk reaction
so when we say around here cash is king
yes actual cash um is part of that but i
also under that say like but you're it's
your money like part of that is meaning
you have the money to pay for something
so whether that's money in a bank
account or that is money you tangibly
have in your hand the idea is yes debt
is dumb
cash is king cash is
your money yes and but studies have a
layer deeper studies have shown that you
spend 12 to 18 percent less
when you spend actual cash you feel the
pain because you feel the pain you're
letting them go of your own money um
versus a debit card i think is a little
bit different but versus a credit card
where you have no emotional attachment
because you know i'm just going to pay
it you know i'm gonna try to pay it at
the end of the month and there's time
and i'm fine you know there's just no
big emotion there
so all that to be said uh i like that
they at least said
that what's in your checking account is
what counts and i'm like is it because
you can track it like if you
you know if i swipe my debit card i have
to track that transaction for me in
every dollar or if you go on your online
bank statement you see it shows up even
though it's already been paid yeah it's
there so i guess their feeling is
once it's gone it's gone and it's not
traceable anymore and it feels freer
generations they grew up in a digital
world for sure for sure yes they're not
used to actually having
cash i thought she was gonna i thought
if the tick tock was gonna go too that
that she didn't know how to make change
or something she had never seen cash
like i thought it was going but it's
funny that it could also be true
you know it didn't even feel real and
okay i
yeah there's a part of me that i i kind
of small part i get it yeah i had some
cash
um i don't even know what it was from
but it was in my purse
and i went schallotsky's is that like a
national chain yeah sandwich chain
schloss keys shallots because it's so
good so i went through and i and i paid
ten dollars you know i was like it was
it was like nine whatever and i paid ten
dollars i was like okay i won't have to
track that in my every dollar app like
it's not going to show up on my bank say
like rachel's admitting it felt free
because that money in my purse was not
saying oh this is my cat this is my food
envelope like i didn't have an intention
for that ten dollar bill i don't even
know where it came from really yeah does
that make sense like so it did kind of
fee i i get the feeling even though it's
really funny to say out loud i love that
it sounded like you were buying
something on the dark web and you were
just buying a sandwich
sandwich
is that how i set it up i haven't even
heard that restaurant name since like
1994. i love that rachel's still holding
oh and number one without black olives
all day rachel's keeping it alive what
do you think what do you think my take
is this i don't think gen z has any real
reason to handle cash and so when they
do get it it's usually a gift from a
relative that's right it's from a
birthday it's from christmas you know
their paychecks are direct deposited and
then they use their card and they never
have to physically touch cash and when
they do have it they go well that was
from a gift and so it didn't really feel
like it's bonus money yes so i can use
this more frivolously that's fair and
that's how i see it okay i'm gonna keep
going because i'm like but then on the
other side all the cash stuffing went
nuts like last month yes where they were
actually cashing out their paychecks and
doing the envelope system they call it
cash stuffing stuffing this folder it's
a new trend that's been around yeah
since like
so some of them are embracing this cash
life and love it because they realize
how responsible you could be with it
we're on the other opposite end it
doesn't even feel like money to them
yeah well and when you see cash now it's
like whoa that's a lot of money because
you don't see money anymore i know and
so it's an interesting uh you know
conversation how do you feel if you were
just if ten dollars just showed up in
your wallet and you can't remember how
it got there i see it and you went to
schalotsky's
got a number one without my columns
how would that would you feel like it
would feel a little bit like bonus money
yeah i wouldn't feel like obligated to
go deposit that in my bank account and
then budget for that i would go okay
sweet i got 10 bucks from wherever sure
uh so so here's my thing if that's you
and you feel that way and you want to
get control of your money go deposit it
into your bank account you can do that
at atms i know they're like what do i
even do with cash you can put it into
the bank that's amazing but if you do
that then it's on your debit card and
you can budget for it you know with
every dollar and all that and even with
every dollar there's simple ways you can
still budget 200 for groceries
and then cash that out into an envelope
and actually spend that cash and track
it yes yes so it's still possible you
don't get an excuse to not budget
because you use cash absolutely yes and
the intentionality and actually it is
very helpful when you're intentional
with cash and you do something like the
envelope system it does help because you
physically you see okay i only have this
much money left and out to eat or the
you know i mean it has a purpose yes
you know i'm a frugal guy rachel so
here's where i use cash every two weeks
i get my hair cut and my barber has a
five dollar discount if you pay with
cash oh and you do it and i do the cash
discount
so i always need to have cash on hand
how much do you pay how much you pay
will you i'll tell i'll tell america how
much i pay it's 35
wow that's really good george i thought
you were gonna be way more boozier than
that no and i'm frugal you know me
rachel i'm always trying to get oh the
hair is great tip i tip okay make sure
you tip your barbers okay for sure so
there we go cash is still king even in
2022 ginzi you hear me it's not free
money budget for it get control of it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by rachel cruz
we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five adam
joins us up next in greenville south
carolina adam welcome to the show
hey george and rachel how you guys doing
we're doing great how can we help
well um i've got a
car problem i'm hoping maybe you guys
could help me make a decision on
i have a very old
uh toyota camry that is uh this is this
is my baby step two and three car nice
and um mechanically i mean i mean this
car is old enough to be registered in
the classic car that's how old it is
what year is it
it is 1997. oh
nice yeah
um mechanically it is still dependable
like it you know it runs fine but the
suspension is pretty much shot
and to get that fixed is probably going
to cost just about what the car is worth
and i'm trying to decide if it'd be
better because like right now you know
the used car market's insane
um so
if i could
potentially upgrade to something for
just a few thousand more
you know
what i've got in my emergency fund would
that be a good idea
so are you in baby step four now do you
have a fully funded emergency fund and
you're out of debt yes yes i am okay
have you been saving for an upgrading
car
i started i mean i i just i should
preface i i just hit baby step four like
in february oh march this is newer so
this is this yeah this is recent
well i would continue saving i i think
at this point you upgrade the car man
you're not in debt there's no reason to
be driving around a 25 year old car at
this point i want you to get a different
kind of dave car which is your upgrade
now that you're out of debt you've
worked hard to do that and build the
emergency fund so i would save up for a
used car paying cash it doesn't need to
be crazy but it needs to be better than
the 97 camry with the shot suspension so
how much can you sell it for when it's
not like just as is
i could probably get about 2 000 for it
maybe okay and it's impressive and if
you fixed it
how much did how much do you say the
repairs were
about 2 000. about 2 000 that's right
about what it's worth and then how much
could you sell it for if it was fixed
i i really don't know if fixing it would
it would up the uh the value of it very
much because it's just like three
thousand okay yeah yeah it's just an old
car sure yeah yeah so i don't i would
sell as is
you know get the 2000 put some money
um
that you need
and it's drivable right i'm trying to
think of how urgent this is for you like
is it yeah yeah it's drivable and it's
still a you know it's a safe car it's
just i'm just
i'm just like i said i've just been
going back and forth on well should i
just drive until the wheels fall off or
yeah
you're getting close to that adam for
sure so yeah
yes i think you've done a great job um
and i think yeah this is the point where
you're able to upgrade and i think that
that's awesome so selling it for 2k
whatever money you have saved over the
next couple of months and and the fact
that you don't you know your emergency
fund and everything is fun that i
wouldn't touch that so i would just save
on the side uh put a couple more grand
together and you could step up
significantly oh yeah to a seven eight
thousand dollar car is going to feel a
whole lot different than what you're
driving right now you're probably
looking at you know a 2010
uh simple sedan i think that would do
the trick and it would feel like a giant
upgrade from what you're driving now but
that's our
logic on it is will you recoup
what you put into it and so if it's
worth two grand and you put two grand in
well it's gotta be worth four grand or
more to be worth it
otherwise just sell it as is and save up
cash and upgrade
okay
awesome thanks
thanks for the call and i think that
that's the
that's the stepping up and car where you
start to you drive like no now so later
you can drive like no one else and so
you know he saves up
you know a couple grand and he steps up
to an eight thousand dollar car he
drives that for maybe a year as he saves
on the side and that's the great thing
about cars they're not forever yeah so
you could there's always again if you
wanted and put the money you saved and
keep just stepping up and so that's the
power and doing it with cash as you do
it slowly but it doesn't mean you can
never have a great car yes people think
well the ramsey plan is you drive crappy
cars your whole life mm-hmm you look in
our parking lot there's there's some
real nice cars out there and there's
some beater cars out there people are
all over their money journey so adam
you've done the work to get out of debt
so i just want you to upgrade because i
want that for you you deserve it at this
point you've done the hard work thank
you so much tracy joins us up next in
grand rapids tracy welcome to the show
hi long time listener um i have a
a unique question for you i'm 56 years
old i
just was recently divorced the last
eight months i'm sorry um i started a
home-based business in my kitchen
grew and uh moved into a location and i
made it through covid the business is a
little over 12 years old
and i'm broke
i'm not business broke if my business
were just closed and now i own enough
you know i owe nothing on the business
itself i'm also
um
my home is paid for i have a work car
and a pleasure car both paid for but i
am broke so you have no debt but you
also have no savings i have nothing
after the divorce i have i mean i i
shouldn't say i have nothing i have
no money the business has a small
cushion um but i have nothing okay how
much do you make a year tracy in your
business i've always just put my
business i put the money back into the
business
i'm a wedding and events forest and it's
an ever-changing industry and you are
ever keeping up with the changes so the
money just went back into the business
how are you eating though like how are
you how are you paying your bills well i
do make draws so
um
what would you say is your net income
per
month
or what you take out to pay your bills
monthly probably less than a thousand
okay so tracy because of your age and
where you're at like i understand
putting money back in the business but
you also have to watch out for yourself
do you think the business is everyone
get to a point where you can sell it
i you know it's it's the type of
business that um no i don't believe i
could sell it you kind of own a job
yeah yeah i um
there's
uh
mom and pop florists just hardly exist
anymore sure
i believe that it would not be a
sellable business okay
um so tracy what i want you to do though
is um
map out
what the next 20 years of your life
looks like so that's everything from
when you want to retire if you want to
maybe you're one of those people that
just loves to work
but you want to start to have these
savings goals to put away money right so
you're you know i want you to to take
these
take advantage of these retirement
vehicles with investing like a roth ira
and i want you to really
push into that because you want to have
money saved for the future because
there's one day that you're not going to
want to work and you're going to want to
retire i don't know if that's in 10
years or 20 years
but you need to sit down and really
understand that and i would sit down
with the smart fester pro and map this
out because they're going to help put
you in funds because you need to start
you need to start investing and you're
you're still relatively young i mean
you're 56 so you know you're you still
have decades ahead of you
but to figure out what's the smartest
way to go about this to get you the most
money as possible but that's also going
to require you to take money out of the
business and pay yourself
um what you're able to so that you have
a future yeah and tracy i want you to
ask yourself a hard question
is the business worth it
because right now you're making ten
thousand dollars a year
busting your butt in this business could
you go work for another florist and make
more than that
yeah oh
that would be hard to do i'm sure i
could do that i know this is your baby
i'm sorry this is your baby right yeah
yeah i you know survived covet i started
um this you know in my kitchen
and it's a beautiful business and
yeah and i do want to retire
yeah and that's where i think you have
the hard the hard conversation whether
that's with a friend uh where you go all
right i need to find maybe a different
career path right now and maybe this
becomes my hobby passion project on the
weekends that i do but right now you
need a way to make way more income than
a thousand dollars if you ever plan on
retiring
yeah
do you think you have more in the
business because when you say that
you're just putting everything back in
the business is there money
avail like are you making more and
you're just being overly cautious to
keep this business afloat like could you
be paying yourself more or is that about
what you're taking i absolutely i
absolutely could i want you to look at
the books of your business and stuff
before you do that because what george
is saying is right though you may
that may come to that crossroads where
you realize wow
because of my age and everything that's
going on circumstantially i need to put
more money away and maybe the business
allows you to do that and you just have
to let go of that control
to do that or there might be a different
path but i'm sorry tracy you've been
through a lot
a lot the last 12 months so um we're
thinking about you for sure you you're
definitely got the perseverance down
that's for sure and that will get you a
long way rooting for you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by rachel
cruz and we are taking your calls your
career your relationships your money
it all happens right here on the ramsay
show
brennan joins us up next in virginia
brennan welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help
yeah i just wanted to touch base with
you guys and
you know i'm 27 um i have a home
i still have college debt i have um a
car loan
and i have investments in crypto um
and really just want to navigate i have
forty thousand dollars saved um in my
in my savings and i just want to talk to
you guys and see what is the next you
know best path forward um you know for
financial freedom yeah it's a great
question how much uh student loan debt
do you have left
i only have 34 000 34 and how much is
the car
payment
sorry the car loan
16 000.15 okay and you said you have a
home you have a mortgage
yes sir okay
but i got a sweet deal on that so the
home is valued at 420 000. i only owe
200 000
okay and how much do you have in crypto
14 000 okay
well you did great saving up i mean you
have a you have a great savings account
starting out um
so
overall here here's the way we we kind
of take our stands brandon so
we want you to be on the path of the
fastest possible way to have financial
peace and to build wealth and so what we
have found
over decades is that fastest path is
being completely debt free because your
largest wealth building tool is your
income and when your income comes in and
it's not going back out to student loans
and a car payment
you have more money to go and invest in
things that have long track records
and so getting to that point is really
where where we would suggest you go so
what does that mean that means if i'm in
your if i woke up in your shoes
um and george you can answer this
question if anything's different but for
me if i woke up in rachel's heels
what would you do
uh i
i would get out of the crypto i'd sell
it cash it out
get your 14 000 because then you're
gonna have fifty four thousand dollars
uh in savings and you're gonna be able
to
knock out all your debt right there and
so being able to pay off the car i'd pay
that off tomorrow
go ahead and pay off the student loans
and then build up a three to six month
worth of expenses
emergency fund the fully funded
emergency fund
you can put that in a money market
account a savings account but just
having that buffer of cash
that if or when something happens just
in case it's there
and then i would start investing 15 of
your income into retirement and
when we talk about investing it really
is the things that have proven track
records and so we love mutual funds if
you have a job that offers a 401k and a
match doing that taking you know getting
into a roth ira
having these elements that
involve compound interest and again
being in the market some and right now
it's on sale because it's down uh but
really seeing okay what are the things
that have long track records and then at
that point if you want to get back into
crypto a little bit i think that's
totally fine if it's a small percentage
of your world i just wouldn't have a ton
of money in something that does not have
a long track record and crypto could get
there um but as of right now i would put
myself in a position where i'm debt free
and have cash in the bank
how does that hit you brendan
yeah
that i kind of knew what you guys were
going to say i just wanted to hear it
from you know from the horse's mouth so
to speak um he called you a horse rachel
[Music]
i don't take offense of that
yeah okay um i meant like the pros um
but
so
i've been talking to my father about it
as well and he you know he said
something along the lines of doubling
about my payments that way
oh
just so you guys know
i also so
um i make about 75 000 a year
and um
and um
so
but i also ran out two of my rooms so 75
of my mortgage is paid for oh awesome so
yeah and luckily you know i have good
roommates
um
and i'm not in a committed relationship
thank god um so
what the next part is is do i
what i was really thinking of do i pay
off the car
and
make double payments on the student
loans and then invest into a roth ira
what what my car came was well i think
you're going to be able to be if i'm
real you can kind of just pay everything
off
and then and then you're going to be
investing really soon in the the time
frame between now and when you after you
have your fully funded emergency fund
it's not going to be that long maybe a
couple of months for you because you're
already ahead five grand in what you
have right now and you don't have a ton
of expenses um as a single guy so i
think you'll be investing really really
soon anyways if i if this was going to
take you five years until you start
investing then i would still have the
same answer but i would also be like oh
i know that doesn't feel great but i
think brendan you're gonna be able to
start you're gonna be able to invest
here in the next like five months i
think you would open something up and
that in that time period is not going to
make or break you i would rather you
be completely debt free of no payments
have some cash in the bank and then you
can really start investing at that point
brandon what got you here isn't going to
get you there what i'm saying is you're
doing a lot of things right now all at
once and it's not getting you to where
you want to go and so when i started
this plan back in 2013 i had about this
similar debt you had i had forty
thousand dollars in debt student loans
credit cards and i followed the baby
steps i put a thousand dollars aside the
rest went towards that i had to cash out
some uh stocks i had from apple when i
worked there as part of their employee
stock purchase program i cashed that it
hurt to cash that out but man seeing
that debt go away and seeing those
payments go away and have that income
back in my life and then i went oh i
have so much more money to invest now
when i don't have any payments and so
the good news is on paper you could be
close to debt free today
if you cashed out the crypto and used
all the savings except for a thousand
dollars that would get you almost to
debt freedom and then you save up that
three to six months which with your
income and you renting out those rooms
you're going to be able to do in a few
months and then you're going to be able
to invest 15
and then you can start betting on crypto
again
so this is not a five-year plan we're
talking
within the next six seven months you're
in a very different place financially
right
that's what i wanted to hear that's he's
sold he is sold we're gonna get off this
call and he's gonna say yes i'm gonna do
exactly
shoot me straight brennan what's the
hold up i can tell you're not you're not
wanting to do this
well the the the trade-off is is that
you know i know that crypto's very
speculative market and that and that
honestly is an indication of the price
fluctuation and i think we all know that
especially people that understand the
financial world it's all right now based
on speculation but
there are going to be winners and losers
in the space
and it's you do your due diligence and
you find out
what those true winners are that bring
real world utility
it's almost
it's almost you should bet on that
because the the
upside to that it's almost like well why
not put fourteen thousand dollars that
you can afford to lose you can't afford
it and you're broke dude
okay i don't know what to tell you i
mean on paper
i know you're you're here's 40 000 in
the savings and you have
what is it 49 000 in
in debt
no that's not right right
here's the thing i'm hearing language
like this you said multiple times well i
only have 34 000 student loans well i
only have 15 000 on my car well i only
owe 200 000 on my house
as long as you see debt in that way
you can't build wealth
because you see debt as a tool to be
leveraged and clearly it's not working
you're doing too many things at once and
i want you to win man i'm really rooting
for you and i'm not mad at crypto this
is not a thing i'm not bashing crypto i
don't care what if it was single stocks
i'd tell you to cash it out right now
what you need to do is clean up this
mess so you can have your greatest
wealth building tool back in your life
your income
that's what we're here to do we're not
here to tell you you're doing things
wrong i think it's awesome that you're
27 and you own a house and you clearly
know a thing or two and you're smart i
mean you have roommates they're helping
pay them more i mean yeah you're do
you're doing it right but the problem
too is is over time when you just keep
sitting in this
you're it's going to take you longer to
build wealth and again our plan is to
get to the fastest point from point a to
point b how do you do that and we found
time and time again not just in a math
sense too but also there's an emotional
spiritual sense too that when you do not
owe anyone anything
you have options and investing in things
that have long track records that have
been proven over time is the wisest way
to get from point a to point b preach
rachel preach that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to my
co-hosts rachel cruz all the folks in
the booth and you america we appreciate
you listening and we will be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living and being well
i'm george campbell your host joined
today by my co-host rachel cruz
best-selling author and host of the
rachel cruz show we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your money your
career your work your life your
relationships inflation teslas we can
talk about it all right here when dave's
not here
that's what it's all about that's what
it is that's that's the real reason we
want to do this show
katie joins us up next she is in paducah
kentucky
katie welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can rachel and i help
um
back in march i decided to do financial
peace university and i am in baby step
two i'm working my way through it
awesome i work full time for the usda
and i make quilts for people and i also
own two horses and get horseback lessons
wow
unfortunately last week my main horse
that i do all my lessons on is injured
and
we're taking him to a performance vet
here in a couple of weeks to try and
figure out what's going on so
my side income of horseback lessons is
went from 300 a month to zero and um i
only make about thirty four thousand a
year at the moment so every single penny
counts at the moment
and i'm racking my brain trying to think
of new side hustle ideas to make up the
difference since
my main lesson horse is out
okay
so
what are you making from the quilts
every month
um it's very inconsistent
it's
ranges from 200 to 350 every other month
or so every other month so let's call it
100 bucks a month
yes okay
and you're making 34.
do you think that you could make more
elsewhere is it time to look for a
different job doing the same thing
i started this job back in january i
graduated college in 2021 and i was a
veterinary technologist for three years
and i was only making 12 dollars an hour
and then this job with the usda opened
and so i switched to the usda and i
jumped from 12 an hour to 17 and so now
this is the most
salary i've ever made um so i've already
hit a big difference but i'm not opposed
to trying to switch dogs to increase
salary okay i'm just thinking with this
job market and how much people are
willing to pay yeah um you could do just
what was the what were the things you
did in that first job you explained what
was it more administrate what
administrative
type role what was that that you're
doing for three years
um what i was doing for three years
yes
okay i was a veterinary technologist so
i assisted vets
um i did treatments on hospitalized
patients uh help with surgery place ivs
okay um stuff like that
okay which is a pretty big skill set i'm
like that's that's impressive so i just
wonder katie if there i mean i know i'm
sure you have a love for horses
um and a love for what you do which is
awesome i just wonder if there's a way
for you
to either take those same passions or
something you're doing in your previous
job where you know maybe animals are
still
part of your career but but right now is
the best time
to be making money katie i mean the the
job market it's unbelievable what people
are paying now for labor um is
incredible so for you to replace
300 a month i don't have any hesitation
that you can do that even by just
driving uber and doing uber eats i mean
there's so many
so many side hustles like that that you
could pick up and oh god a heartbeat
could be making more than 300
a month but your goal too is to to have
a career of something that you're
passionate about and that you love ken
coleman talks about that a lot here on
this show so i would love for you to
find something
that maybe is just more full-time
instead of kind of piecing these things
together that gives you more of that
consistent lift to be making more money
unless you find a different way to make
more money doing these things but i'm
not sure just thinking dog sitting dog
walking
pet sitting boarding you can make really
good money doing that katie's with your
love for animals have you seen a need
for that in your area
well i live in a very rural area i know
it said paducah i actually live in
murray kentucky i'm about an hour from
paducah and i live in a town about 30
000.
and um
i switched from being a vet tech to
working for the government because of
the pay raise that i got
and so instead of working 60 hour weeks
as a technologist now i work 40 hours a
week make more money and then i had
extra time
to do the lessons and the quilts and
with this cost of fuel i'm scared to
like door dash or anything but since i
live in such a rural area i'm not even
sure if that would be a possibility or
dog walking or dog sitting yeah so how
much debt do you have
i have i started out at 125 000 and i've
knocked it down to about 118 so far okay
what kind of debt is this
it is
student loans
credit card debt a line of credit
and um a family loan
okay
so here's my thing are you doing a
budget every month currently
yes okay
what i want you to do is stop the
bleeding obviously stop going into debt
i'm guessing you haven't gone further
into debt during this process
that is correct okay good i do think we
need to up this income i mean with this
pile of debt you have this is not going
to happen in a year or two unless we up
this income to double what it is now
and that might mean working 60 70 hours
a week i don't know that now is the time
to you know jumping into small business
and passion projects right now is the
time to do whatever it takes yeah work
at whatever store is willing to pay you
15 20 bucks an hour and busting your
tail until this debt's gone yeah katie
this is this is the situation of of kind
of that urgency of of getting it's it's
kind of that matt we talking about
getting mad
at your situation and be like i have a
hundred and eighteen thousand dollars
in debt through all this stuff and i
want this cleaned up as fast as possible
and i will do anything i will do
anything to get this out of my life and
that's gonna mean not doing maybe
working the jobs that you yeah that your
heart and your passion is not the thing
i mean there's some sacrifice here and
he and now's the time to do it katie
you're still young
you just graduated last year from school
and this is the time to do it i'm like
it's not going to get easier and so put
in the hours i mean i really want i want
you to go crazy i want you to go back to
60 hours a week because you picked up 20
more hours somewhere else that you're
working and so
really hitting this hard katie and your
mindset has to change if you keep doing
what you've been doing you're going to
keep getting what you've been getting
and so
i i would just flip my whole mindset
upside down and think okay
it's time to get it's time to get
serious and it's time to really do this
and be budgeting every single month and
every single penny is going towards this
debt and you're going to pay off that
smallest step first and then to the
second smallest and then so on that's
the debt snowball and
and man it it has to have this level of
intensity in your soul katie to really
go after this katie i'm going to give
you a hard challenge could you sell the
horse
would you do it
i can't
why not
i've had this horse 11 years and katie
katie katie there's other horses out
there it doesn't even know your name
there's more horses for you on the other
side
listen i want katie to win my gosh she's
got a mess to clean up i'm doing
whatever it takes i'll get another horse
later this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by rachel
cruz all right rachel i have to
backtrack man that went out like that
was uh i just hit like the third rail
and i got so much hate from everyone in
the booth everyone in the lobby no the
lobby all you had some hands well
there's a few bros in the lobby that are
on team george here's what happened
katie called in
making 34 grand a year she has 118 000
in debt
rural area not a lot of ways to up the
income and she has two horses so one
horse
one horse is injured and we're nervous
about the vet bills of what that's going
to cost
yes we'll throw that out there that we
didn't we didn't touch on that that's
true and there's another horse that's in
perfectly good condition and i just
threw it out there because she's broke
and this is a dire situation
what if
you sold the horse i don't know and you
would have thought i said shoot the
horse
you would have thought i said that based
on the reaction
oh please don't email us just go for it
does anyone know i mean thousands of
dollars i imagine like how like wait
what is thousands like ten thousand
ten thousand okay our engineers saying
ten grand rachel come on if it was a car
we'd say sell it but because it has a
soul you're saying if it was a house
well the only thing that makes me
nervous is what these vet built she i
don't know if she can afford to have a
horse to take care of me
rachel i know but you made it sound like
you said sell the horse to get out of
debt
if you can maintain it how much is your
dog george i'm not broke rachel
that's the difference but yeah so
the the the logic though here is if you
have something in your life that you
cannot financially take care of
um that is not a person let me say that
sure
uh
then that's when you start to look and
say okay when do when does something
become more of a curse than a blessing
in my life and that can be a house that
could be a car you could fill in
whatever you want to there so that was
the mindset you were thinking with this
i was not trying to be insensitive i
love horses they're wonderful creatures
great pets but i'm just going i'm
looking around going what are the
options here yeah and it's and
there's something with pets y'all and
again we are pet people once we just got
a puppy we had a lab for 12 years like
we are we love pets we love dogs all
that i'm not a horse i don't know much
about horses but
uh we i had a call on the show this was
probably months ago with dave and there
was a lady and she i can't even remember
she had tons of debt i think it was
maybe over a hundred thousand living in
an apartment with two dogs her apartment
um rent was insane but she couldn't move
because she had these two dolls it was
like this whole thing and literally her
two she was sacrificing her life and her
financial well-being
because of these dogs like these dogs
played such this role in her life right
and again we
love animals yes but when something
becomes such a barrier um in your life
that you can't make wise decisions going
forward that's when you have to ask
yourself hard questions thank you is
that fine yes thank you for when you
have 10 seconds left george was sweet
katie on the phone and that was my
buzzer beater roll it out little three
points sell the horse they said sell the
car george says sell the horse and then
you get on a break you got
rachel every time i take a call by
horses it goes south
the last one this guy called in and said
hey should i lease a horse i don't know
if it's a horse yes and so we absolutely
said no don't lease a horse save up pay
cash and then they came at us in the
comments going this guy doesn't
understand anything about horse leasing
you're right that was not part of the
plan there's no playbook on horse
leasing and so they're explaining to me
that it's more like renting a horse well
then why not call it rent a horse
instead of leasing a horse leasing 100
chance you've gotten canceled in the
horse culture yes horse culture has
canceled me don't cancel don't email me
care about this black beauty is like my
favorite movie so you guys are kind of
beating a dead horse here time to move
meeting the dead horse
thank you james all right just go to
justin in texas justin
justin's in victoria texas and i pray to
god he does not own a horse uh justin
are you with us justin do you have a
horse
i think i messed it up there he goes
justin with us justin do you want do you
own a horse
i don't i've never even been on my horse
okay
okay how can we help you
you're okay
well um a little bit of a backstory then
i'll get to my question um in february
of last year um i quit my job looking
for dominoes to be a full-time caregiver
for my mom who has just come back from
a nursing home she spent most of 2020 in
the hospital with sepsis getting
dialysis breast cancer a lot
um i'm an only child and i grew up in
poverty almost my entire life so i felt
like it was just my duty because i'm all
she had the nursing home would have
taken all of her social security well
it financially ruined me
because i wasn't working i was just
doing side gigs you know maybe when i
had to
but in
december just a few days after christmas
i lost her to a heart to heart failure
oh justin i'm sorry
it was in shock to us because she was
doing so good he stunned all this
but um i'm living in the manufacturing
home that she bought and it's an old it
just to show how old this house is it's
older than yours than dave's radio show
wow this thing was built in 1989 and the
value is about three thousand i'm only
paying about 400 a month with a lot rain
and and the fees they charge
but honestly
it's a wreck the floor the floor needs
to be fixed the plumbing still hasn't
recovered since the last winter storm
and the the estimate i got with me over
five thousand
now
i'm able to keep my expenses low because
this is such a cheap place to live but
it's just not that good i'm sorry mom
we just couldn't ever fix the house
now
um i'm thinking about moving on maybe
just get a small one-bedroom apartment
but it's gonna cost about
three hundred dollars more per month
between two and three hundred depending
on what kind of place i get
i'm just saying right now i call myself
a baby step two i just
got the baby said too actually i hadn't
used part of my emergency fund last week
but
is it worth it if you're if you're still
trying to pay down debt don't think step
two is it worth it to move to a better
place
when you replace your image i'm trying
to say it's crap so you're saying rent
is going to be 700 a month if you move
these rings into 700 that for one
bedroom one bath when i'm looking around
town and how much
and how much are you making a year
justin right now
um after a long pass i got a job at the
agm of our local chuck e cheese i love
it here it's i'll be making about 35 a
year so
when i figure out the math depending on
how much overtime i get
it will it will be less than a third of
my income which i've heard is the
threshold that should be four monthly
there and how much debt do you have
um i calculated around 55. okay what
what kind of debt is it
it's about 48k in student loan debt
which a lot of it i meant i should never
have taken i'm for i own up to that and
a lot of it is some old um medical debts
that's about 8 000 of it and the rest of
some charitable credit cards one of
which i just got there paying off
negotiate with i was being able to
negotiate with a
collection agency that had it i mean but
he was a bit of a smart aleck he said i
said you know i'm trying to get debt
free i'm trying to learn what dave
ramsey says yeah give me a break this is
america everybody yes
yeah yeah that guy sounds like him
sounds just like yours for credit card
companies could you negotiate the
medical bills
um a lot of them are too high i think
the largest one is 6 000 and the lowest
one is 2 000. they're too high to
negotiate well most of them don't want
to go less than a thousand well have you
asked for hey what would you take in
full to settle this thing today
and the last one i talked to i think the
debt was that medical debt was about
1200 they said the lowest i'll go is
700. okay i'd pay for it in cash and be
done with it so that's my plan of attack
i'm going to go after that medical debt
because it can be negotiated and have
the cash to pay it and get it in writing
to clean that up
at a better rate how many hours do you
work
about 50. how about 10. i guess
i get a full 40 plus a lot of overtime
especially the summer coming up we're
going to be busy yeah so i know i'm
going to get probably even more hours
yeah that's awesome
um okay well
first and foremost i'm so sorry about
your mom um and especially being an only
child and being with her for such a
significant period of time there at the
end of her life as her caregiver i think
is really um
that's an amazing gift that you gave her
um and i really applaud you for that
because that was a a big choice i know
you had to make
um so that's happy whenever i got this
i'm sorry i was so happy when i got this
job i think this was my mom telling the
district manager look he took care of me
for 10 months his job is done he's
waiting for him his job he's going to do
well
let's get the mean away absolutely and
then the second thing justin i would say
too is that there's a you said you you
grew up in poverty um and so there's a
mindset there that you're breaking right
the cycle of saying i don't have to live
like this i can really start to build
wealth and it's going to take time so if
i were you i would be working hard at
your job take as much overtime as
possible even bump it up to 60 65 hours
a week 70 hours away go crazy attack
that medical debt start paying off those
student loans and justin i think you are
on your way and renting an apartment for
700 a month is very reasonable and i
would do that i'll do whatever it takes
to get there man thanks for the call
great job justin you're doing awesome
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by rachel cruz
we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five
five two two five john joins us up next
in the los angeles area john welcome to
the show
[Music]
hello how are you guys good how are you
i'm doing all right what's going on
all right uh so uh i'm a recently
graduated senior and our class uh just
finished the uh
uh the foundations and uh uh personal uh
finances oh awesome awesome
congratulations thank your teacher for
teaching our personal finances thank you
guys
yeah i just want to thank you guys so
much uh because we learned a lot and uh
i really appreciate it that's our
pleasure
so what's going on with you how can we
help
all right so uh today's our last day of
uh class and we just wanted to call in
uh with a question um i am uh
you know i'm getting ready for college
and i have a bit of money saved up i
think i have about a semester's worth
and um i was just wondering uh how would
investing while in college work you know
if if i should do any investing at all
um good question so you said you have a
semester's worth how what's the rest of
your plan to get through college debt
free because that's your goal right now
to invest in yourself yeah
um
i'm sorry i didn't quite understand you
could you free counseling how do you
plan on going through the rest of
college debt-free
um so
during the this summer
before my freshman year i'm going to
work full time and hopefully have about
the rest of the year maybe a little more
paid off and then during the summer i
will work part-time
okay so you're going to do it all
through working paying paying your way
through basically
that's awesome john very good so listen
when it comes to investing in college we
actually say like
it's not necessary even though i know
you guys watch the blake and jack um
you know the power of investing early
the compound interest i know that's in
the curriculum which is awesome and it's
a good teaching point to show the power
of compound interest but really the best
investment you can make right now john
is in yourself and staying in school and
paying your way through and that's going
to give you the best investment at the
end of all of this is graduating
debt-free and then once you graduate
you're 21 i would press and you have no
debt and maybe you even have extra
savings we've even talked to people like
that that are very weird but they do
graduate with an emergency fund yes and
you and you graduate and you have cash
saved or you get your first job and you
save up that emergency fund then press
play on investing then i would start
investing but i would go ahead and get
through your four years of school
um
if you have any extra money saved that
doesn't go to tuition i would put it in
a savings account for next semester i
would just continue
uh to build up a
fund of cash um to use for tuition or
other things and then again when you
graduate maybe you still have some more
money in that account that you're able
to use for your emergency fund or even
to throw in and start investing because
the the amount of time you're gonna
what you're not gonna make up in those
three to four years is worth it of not
it being an investment but it being
towards paying off or continuing to pay
for school does that make sense
yeah that's awesome is your else class
there are you like in class right now
uh yeah that is so that's awesome hey
class is your teacher there can i talk
to them
oh yeah you can talk to him oh this is
who is it what's his name
what's his name over the phone right now
his name is justin engelmann justin just
do you call your teacher jessica wow not
just her mr inkleman i think is the
proper way l a way they're just like
cool they're my first name
yes ma'am hey
welcome to the show we just wanted to
say thank you so much for teaching our
curriculum in your class and helping
this next generation get a handle on
money you're amazing
we've had a great year this year we've
invested a little bit as students and
teaching them and how to save and you
know one of our goals is to get them
through college debt free so john that's
amazing thank you guys i love to hear
that so fun and it's your last day of
school huh
yes ma'am we're at lancaster baptist
school in lancaster california and since
we got on the show the students don't
have to take their final
yes
you can hear them shouting in the
background oh that is so funny i just
channeled my inner high schooler i just
got so excited for them now i feel like
rachel we're like cool now
we help high schoolers skip a fight you
all are welcome now go to school debt
free
i love that well thanks so much for the
call guys it's so cool that is so fun
favorite call of the day right for sure
awesome for those of you that don't know
we have a personal finance curriculum
called foundation personal finance we
have an entire team here the ramsey
education team whose entire day spent
getting this curriculum in schools
helping equip teachers to teach this
course and rachel i've been getting so
many messages because it's the end of
the school year from students saying
like thank you so much we loved the
curriculum it was inspiring it was
awesome we're planning on going to
school debt-free and it warms my heart
i'm like there's hope for the next
generation oh man and what a gift to be
able to
have this knowledge at such a young age
because the decisions you make between
19 and 22 follow you even though not all
18 year olds realize that they follow
you for your life and when it comes to
your money i'm like man to be able to
avoid
so much and just say no and choose a
different path how much quicker
you win with money by just doing that
and now that they have that knowledge
they get to put into practice right yes
and there's this concept i didn't invent
it i don't know but it's it's
pre-deciding
these students are pre-deciding today
the kind of life they're going to live
they're deciding the kind of person
they're going to be
and they're deciding i'm not going to be
the kind of person who has shackles when
i leave college because i thought 150
grand was just monopoly money that i was
going to pay off because i'm going to
make 150 grand the year i graduate high
school college that's the mentality a
lot of students have and so what i love
about this curriculum is we go hey the
culture is lying to you
but there's hope there's a better way if
you can learn to say no to avoid the
comparisons to go to a reasonable school
you can afford in cash to buy a used car
in cash your life is going to be so much
better off for the next 50 years yes oh
so much easier and it's that kind of
line in the sand
that you have to draw and it's an
extreme line to say i'm gonna not i'm
gonna live without debt yeah to say that
is extreme these days well even the kids
going home to their parents and the
parents like what you learned that
credit scores are stupid what are they
teaching you in school i know i know
totally but i love it but it's that but
but having that line drawn so early in
life because i kind of like that was my
story right growing up with big dave
yeah you know teaching us
it was never like a th it was never
a thought for me to even do it because
in my head i'm like well no i'm just
going to work and i have money in my
bank that's off the table so yeah and it
wasn't this extreme thing in my head
because it was so normal in our family
but deciding it that to your point so
early big decisions like that it makes
other decisions
easier because when you take that option
off the table
then it causes you to think different it
causes you to say okay how am i going to
choose something else because when it's
this idea of well i just can't go to
school because i have to i have to take
out loans it's the only way i can go to
school i have to that's the most
dangerous yeah three words and when
that's your mindset right and you say
then it is an option at that point and
you allow yourself to go down the road
but if that's not even an option then
you say okay i have no money how do i go
to school do i choose a different school
my my school selection's going to look
different because i'm not taking out
debt uh the amount of hours i'm going to
work the amount of time i'm going to
apply for scholarships and grant like it
get you ha it forces yourself it forces
your mind to make different options when
you draw a hard light in the sand and
say i'm not going to live with debt and
that's what these students
have done and it's it's an amazing thing
and it's hard four years later they
don't have to shake their fists at the
government and say someone forgive these
loans it's so unfair
instead they go oh i don't have to worry
about that i don't have debt it's not
even it's not even a thing i get to live
my life i get to invest i get to live my
life i can retire early i have options
in here freedom freedom and that's what
well that's what winning with money is
it's not
this end game just to pile up and hoard
a bunch of money to feel good and to buy
a bunch of stuff even though we're not
mad at stuff but that's not the end
point because what wealth actually gives
you it's not just the dollar amount in
your bank account but it gives you
freedom it gives you options it allows
you to give there's an overflow there's
a surplus in your life to sure change
your family tree but to help others
right so it's this it's this cycle it's
not just for you to sit there and hoard
but it gives you other things in life
that you wouldn't be able to have
if you were living paycheck to paycheck
and had debt um and continued in that
mindset with no money when you have that
abundance i this is a hot take i think
it makes you more selfless
because you're able to focus on other
things around you people who need help
where where you can give some money to
help others and so yeah because you're
probably able to get out of debt for
that reason alone i love that because
yeah when you are living paycheck to
paycheck and you owe someone money and
you're going to a job you hate to pay
off this debt
you don't have the capacity to look up
and look at others really i mean i'm
sure there's a time and place but most
of your energy is going to taking care
of yourself because you're having to pay
your bills so once you're free from that
and you have margin again it's it's an
amazing when you do that at 18
that's amazing i'm so excited about this
next generation hey if you want to learn
more about our curriculums that we have
in schools all over we just met with a
senator in florida who got financial
literacy passed as a mandate i'd love to
hear these stories check out
ramseyeducation.com to see what that
team is up to we are big fans of
teachers out there teaching this
curriculum helping those students so
thank you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let me ask you a question when you
think of a millionaire what kind of job
do you picture them having
is it some kind of high-powered
executive position like a vp or a ceo
well here's the thing
only 15 percent of millionaires actually
have jobs like that
the reality is that the top five careers
for millionaires in america are engineer
accountant teacher manager and attorney
that's just one of the surprising things
our team found when we conducted the
largest study of millionaires ever done
we talked to 10 000 millionaires to find
out who they are and how they got there
our study also made it clear that to
become a millionaire you've got to
invest wisely and a big part of that is
getting good investing advice
so you need to work with an investing
pro who can walk with you and teach you
about the options that are right for you
and our team recommends trustworthy
vetted investing pros from all over the
country we call them smart vester pros
so if you want to get in touch with what
a smart investor pro in your area just
go to ramseysolutions.com smart vester
and start building wealth today that's
slash ramsaysolutions.com vester
linda joins us up next in charlotte
north carolina linda welcome to the show
thank you
absolutely how can we help
um i'm on baby step seven and i am
retired
and i want to know what the market the
way it is right now what is the best way
to invest a hundred thousand to a
hundred and fifty thousand
um i've talked with a smart pro
a smart investor pro and
they kind of want to assume all of my
portfolio which is a little over a
million dollars and they charge ten
thousand dollars a year to do that about
one percent one and a quarter percent
and i was just wondering um
what the smart thing way to invest and
that would be
yeah well first of all congrats baby
step seven you got a paid for house
you're retired how's retirement going
very good thank you good well i can tell
it's very relaxing when you have money
so this is a good problem to have so you
got you got about a hundred thousand to
invest and you're wondering what the
right way to do it and you contacted a
smart investor pro and what you're
talking about is assets under management
so they charge a yearly fee
uh in order to do that and one percent
is kind of the industry standard
and you're saying hey should i be giving
the 10 000 to the smartvestor pro or is
there something i should be doing on my
own
yes um another investor that i have most
of my portfolio with from
years ago
recommended getting a three-year bank cd
that pays arena quarter three and a half
percent
how old are you linda i know
i am 67 67 okay
i at your age i would not no i would not
i would not put this money in a cd i i
mean okay still at your age i agree
you're i mean you still
i mean god willing i'm like you could
still have 20 years left linda right 20
maybe even 30 years even 30 years um so
that's still a significant i mean that's
that's two three decades that you
possibly could still have so
um that you could be in the market so if
i were you
um i trust our smart investor pros i
mean that we we vet them and we
we really do they they do the ramsey way
and if they don't yeah people call us
let us know but but they really do what
we teach and i think because of your age
i think even if you just got in a mutual
fund and still even though it's kind of
crazy right now because of the market
when you actually have money though and
you have you're set up so well
really the way to look at it is that
things are on sale right now you can
actually be buying a whole lot more
because i think the market will recover
uh we believe in the american economy
enough to know that it will recover
um out of this and
and yeah if i were you i would i would
put money in the market i'd put that 100
grand and unless there's something else
that you're wanting to do with it i
don't know if even real estate if you
you know if there's something else you
don't want to you want to do but at this
point you may not even want to mess with
anything
and putting it and parking it somewhere
and even just living off that interest
yeah do you need this income linda
no i don't okay so this is like bonus
fun money right now but you just want to
stew it at work
and it's okay
i guess i have trouble trusting someone
that i just met
it's okay to basically follow all their
suggestions they're probably going to
want to manage the whole portfolio which
means
moving funds over to them
well they're going to do whatever you're
comfortable with so if any any financial
advisors yeah
your job is to tell them what to do
their job is to advise you
on what the best options are but they're
not going to do anything for you they're
going to educate you on what your best
route is and linda never the summer
advice always no matter your age and
situation never put your money in
something you do not understand
so if there's throwing terms out and
you're thinking oh god i mean i guess
you don't just blindly trust them
because they are smart investor pro or
they're an investment professional or
whoever it is
you need to fully understand and ask
questions
um before you put your money in i want
you to be completely comfortable with it
and again they're not going to just tell
you what to do they should advise you
and even give you different options and
different routes and
and the prayer is that they have a heart
of a teacher that they're there to help
you understand and know what's going on
it's not going to be this
or yeah this experience of oh gosh
here's all these terms i have no idea
and i feel intimidated and so i'm gonna
just trust because george and rachel
said to do it i want you to feel
comfortable and then if you don't feel
comfortable don't do it
no we just had one initial meeting and
it was um just kind of like a
preliminary and um i did feel very
comfortable with him as soon as i met
him
and but then they're like as the days
are passing by then i i just get cold
feet sure because i just
well it's scary i mean you guys have
worked so hard to build this wealth and
you've done an amazing job and so you're
wise to go hey i want to make sure that
hold on to it yeah whoever i work with i
trust and so here's one thing on the fee
if this helps you
their job is to choose funds that
outperform the market
so if you look at the average over the
last 30 years you know you're looking at
10 11 12
and so to pay someone one percent to get
me 11 return you're still doing real
good you're still making six figures a
year on that compound growth and so i
don't want the one percent to scare you
off from ever yeah leaving this money in
a cd or a savings account where it can't
even keep up with inflation instead of
still making 9 10 11
uh you know when the market's doing well
so i want to encourage you that don't
let the fees carry away do it when you
feel ready when you understand it
okay thank you so much for the call
linda way to go well baby steps
millionaire right there yeah amazing
great work tony's in sacramento tony
welcome to the show
hi how's it going great how can we help
so my dad left me a house and um
mom's been kind of knowing about that
she wants to move in now
but the tenants have been moved out uh
so the place is empty
and i want to move in
and one must have tagged along uh
however she has a bit of a gambling and
a drug addiction problem
not too sure on what to do about
something like that it's been that way
since i was a kid
so something even has changed
yeah things are rough
oh that's hard um were your parents
together were they divorced when he left
you this home
um actually you know my dad was about uh
he was uh late 70s when he had me and
mom was early
40s i didn't believe okay
so were they still married big
difference they were not married at all
oh at all okay i'm sorry i'm sorry okay
so he
left you this home
and there were tenants in there they've
moved out so now you're wanting to move
in to the gift that your dad left you
and now your mom
is wanting to come in is has she um
has she been through programs has she
has she tried to get clean before
no i mean i'm sure she's tried on her
own but of course
that's a very difficult journey on her
own self
she hasn't tried anything professional
which i would feel is completely
beneficial for her but
um many places that i've talked to it
takes her to kind of
you know make the first
step i don't want to give her the
resources you know bring the horse to
water
of course yeah do you
is there a part do is the most does the
big part of you
want her to move in because you feel
like you want to help or you feel
obligated and you dread it
well i kind of want to help her but i
feel like if she doesn't want to change
herself if she doesn't feel like there's
anything wrong with the way she's doing
things uh there might not be it might be
a fruitless endeavor yes yeah i see this
as a form of enabling because she's now
going to have no payments i'm guessing
if she lives there
and you're going to be kind of enabling
this behavior she's not going to get
better and so i think you need to set up
some hard boundaries and have a hard
conversation with her and go mom i love
you but you got to get better and i want
to be a part of your life but i can
understand i want to help you on this
journey and i will help pay for
treatment but i need you to step up
um in order to do that such a hard
situation i'm so sorry tony
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by rachel cruz best-selling author and
host of the rachel cruz show we're
taking your calls to give you the right
next step with your money your work the
housing market cars inflation you name
it so give us a call triple eight eight
two five
anthony kicks off this hour in
huntsville alabama anthony welcome to
the show
how you doing uh rachel and george can
you hear me yes you sound great what's
going on
thank you um my wife and i are in baby
step two we have a car lease it's 413
a month and there's 22 months left on it
and then our other debt remaining is uh
student loans they're 12 individual uh
federal student loans that total about
forty five thousand dollars and we're
struggling on how to order this uh which
ones to pay off first we do have
six thousand dollars that we can use to
go get a car and we just don't know if
we should put it on the student loans or
get this car thing sorted out
do you know the early buyout amount on
the car
um i've checked it several times but not
recently so it always changes i think
it's somewhere around like 35 it's a
jeep gladiator so
what's your income
um combined we're at about 150 000. okay
there's some good news there we got a
nice shovel to clean this up yeah
and that's the total debt
is the 45 student loans plus the car
lease
yep 45 months and probably that's all of
it
well
do you like the car
um
i don't my wife loves it
because right now i mean as part of your
financial world um it's not that big i'm
okay with you keeping the car if you
want to do the early buy out
but you've got quite the mess here to
clean up still with you know what
80 000 in debt
yeah
because kind of the rule of thumb to
anthony is
we don't want your card to be
half of
your annual income so it's not getting
close to that but um i mean getting out
of this lease
yeah because if you get out of that you
have 6 000 i'd go buy a you know a cheap
beater car which in this market 6000
gets you a beater car unfortunately yeah
we saw a toyota prius for sale in 2006
and we'd be going from a truck to a
prius but i'm kind of willing to do it
my wife doesn't know if we should lose
the security of the lease being you know
that it won't break down
and uh we've come to terms come to the
terms that we're paying off these loans
even though everybody thinks the
government's going to forgive them we're
paying them off these federal loans
that's awesome that's awesome yeah
that's awesome well right now you have
the illusion of security you don't have
financial security
and the idea of your car is just
constantly breaking down because you
drive a used car is a myth i think a lot
of people truthfully use it to justify
why they need to keep
their nice new shiny car
um and so that that's gonna be the
toughest part honestly is the
conversation with your wife about
getting rid of this car
if you're not gonna keep it
yeah i don't think we were planning on
buying it at the end anyways
it's a lot of money for it she likes it
a lot and it is a nice car but
yeah we want to own our car and we don't
really need a 35 000 car i don't think
yes so i think that's that's the feeling
that's it and especially if it's not
something that you were going to buy
even at the end of the lease
i think letting it go now i think you
guys are going to break that's going to
hurt and it's not going to be fun but i
think it's the wisest decision right now
looking at the numbers for you guys and
then that way you can start attacking
this debt and you guys make a great
income too anthony so you're going to be
on the other side of this really quickly
okay
all right let's see sometimes we just
make it sound so simple and i've been
sleeping soon over this for days
yeah we tend to do that we try to over
complicate things and the truth is the
money plan that we uh pitch here on the
show is real simple and it's real hard
because it involves emotion it involves
behavior it involves sacrifice and
saying no delayed gratification
uh all thing you know it really harkens
back to our childhood days rachel uh
when we're kids you know and we just
want the things we want we want it now
and so we go do it and we go oh that was
a mistake how do we get out of this yep
for sure for sure well thanks anthony
thanks for the call yeah appreciate that
nick joins us in denver colorado up next
nick welcome to the show
thank you thank you
what's going on um so currently
uh
me and my wife uh we have a house here
and um i guess just a quick rundown on
it we're on a 15-year loan we're
1.75 interest rate and we pay 1740 a
month for our mortgage
um we get a thousand dollars a month for
a studio that we have on it
nice
um so we bought the house in 2018 of
course property values
everything's doubled
um
we bought the house for 275. we could
probably
sell it for 600 000. awesome um
so the other thing is that we have now
is we currently have another house
we hear we have a little baby starting
our family
so we need to
upgrade
need a bigger house
we have some family that has a house
that they offer to us
it's much bigger
um
we can get it for a really good deal for
what the current real estate market is
they're going to sell it below market to
you
yes wow they are that's generous um
yeah
no that's why it's a good opportunity
to figure out whether we should keep our
house
here how much is the new house um
the new house is 450.
it's 450 and we have a hundred thousand
down to put on it
that's your equity in the current home
no that's what we have uh
if you didn't sell the currency you
still have 100 thousand in cash to put
down
yes okay and if you did sell your
current house how much could you put
down
could you pay cash
you could sell for a 600 600 000 you
said
yeah yeah so they can pay cash for it
and but they have a mortgage on it
so how much equity do you have in the
current house
oh we have
well it's worth yeah we can sell for six
hundred thousand we uh owe 230 on it oh
okay
okay good question at like 350. so what
i'm saying though you got 350 off the
sale of your house plus the 100 grand
you have boom you just paid cash for
this house and you don't have a payment
anymore
right so if i'm in your shoes that's
what i'm doing i do not like the idea of
you having two mortgages even if you can
make it work on paper
from a risk management level having no
payments is better than having two
okay
um you know one thing uh our goal with
this myself i don't have a retirement
because of my
i guess my career choice
what's your career
um i'm a hunting guide and uh ranch hand
and stuff like that so cool nice my
husband's dream job so
yeah
i'm very lucky and fortunate my wife's a
nurse so
uh we're we're pretty secure which is
nice
we did you know kind of when we bought
this house we were looking at it as a
retirement board
well i don't like a home as a retirement
plan because that's going to be real
hard to create a meaningful income off
of that so my my principals still stand
rachel you can disagree here but i'm
going sell it pay cash for the next one
then you'll be able to stack up real
fast you can do investment property
later with cash you can actually start
to save for retirement that's what i
would be doing that feels a lot safer
that's financial peace this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
we've laughed over the years at how
people have tried to call dave ramsey
and the growth of ramsey solutions at
quote overnight success on the surface
it makes for a much more exciting story
but we've seen enough stupid to know
that overnight success is too short and
shallow to produce anything with
momentum and meaning so if you want
unstoppable momentum in all areas of
your life you have to focus and spend
time in the trenches and invite god into
your efforts then you will see amazing
things happen
now creating momentum is hard it isn't
for everyone not everyone is ready for
that next level of living but if you are
we've got great news dave ramsey has
written a new quick read called the
momentum theorem to give you our formula
for unstoppable momentum and the cool
thing is the momentum theorem is not
exclusive to just his story it can be
your story too
you can shift gears in any area of your
life at any time you can turn the dial
in your business leadership marriage
parenting health finances and faith
now this is a value we've lived out here
at ramsey solutions for a long time it's
one of our core values and this is how
you get out of debt this is how you
create an amazing marriage this is how
you build an amazing business like
ramsey solutions so go check this out
it's like 43 pages you can read it in
one sitting but it could change the
trajectory of your life so go get your
copy of the momentum theorem for just
ten dollars at ramseysolutions.com
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined by rachel cruz today and
nicole is up next she's in augusta maine
uh nicole welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call absolutely how can i help
so um me and my husband just sold our
house and we were able to become debt
free and put yeah fifteen thousand yeah
i know so exciting
um and put fifteen thousand away for
emergency fund
and yeah now we have
fifty thousand dollars left
we currently put 15
of my husband's paycheck into his psp
because he's in the military i'm going
to school so i don't have any retirement
funds started so we have 50 000
and we want to go on a vacation and we
want to buy some new stuff for our new
house but i also want to um you know
invest it and just looking for your
guys's advice
cool so you you sold the house you
catapulted through baby step two and
three into baby step four and you said
you're in a new house now did you
purchase a new home are you renting
um actually we are living with friends
right now he's getting restationed so we
are renting at um his new station okay
cool so you're running you're saying you
want to buy some stuff for the new place
and you want to go on a vacation
what's your hesitation with doing that
um just i want to i wanted to open up a
roth ira so i was curious and i we
wanted to put some money into that and
start like enough because we have the
tsp and we wanted to start like another
um thing for like retirement um i just
didn't know how much i should put in
there and how much should i spend on
vacation
yeah it's all a great question um
yeah i mean i think if i were you guys
yeah the i mean you could take that 15
of the 50 000
uh if you wanted to look at it that way
you could do that um and put around you
know 7 000 into a roth ira this year
fully fund a roth ira and then take the
remainder you know a little bit of that
go on a reasonable vacation yep um how
much stuff do you want to get for the
new place what are we talking a few
grand um yeah just a few grand we really
just need a dining room table
um we want a new bed and then maybe a
new couch but what our two focuses is a
new dining room table and a new bed
cool have you priced out what you guys
would want and something like that
because that furniture just can range so
i didn't know if you had an idea
yeah a little bit um so i'm i would say
a dining room table and fine keeping
under like a thousand or fifteen hundred
and then a bed we haven't really priced
out that much um we haven't looked too
much but i would say maybe between like
uh three thousand or four thousand for
like a really nice bed
yep yeah well the great thing is y'all
have the ability to be able to do a lot
with those 50 000. so i think yeah i
think go ahead and get get the furniture
you want spend five six thousand on that
what's your income
uh my husband's income because i'm a
full-time nursing student right now um
his income is probably about 70 75 000 a
year
cool
well you guys have made the sacrifices
to get to where you are so i'm totally
good with you making some purchases and
enjoying some of this money but just
balance that with the opportunity cost
of okay if we want to buy a home down
the road well that's our down payment
money that we're eating away from which
is okay we got to go on vacations we
have to have a bed and a dining table
but we don't need to go crazy and go
we're going to buy the nicest of
everything while we rent and then you
move into the new house and you go well
the dining table doesn't fit in that
spot anymore
and now we don't need it okay you know
so i just want you to think about the
long term as well yeah do you guys move
a lot because of his job is he stationed
do you guys yes yeah we move yeah we'll
be in his new station for three years
and we plan to rent for the three years
and um yeah we have no idea what the
what's gonna happen in the future we'd
like to build a house and we decide to
get somewhere so that's kind of an end
goal um but so you guys would just
recommend putting about five six
thousand and opening up a roth ira
yes i would yeah going forward you know
just invest 15 of your household income
so if you're still in school that's 15
percent of his 75 into the tsp and
beyond that you know you can start
saving
ira as well
yep
um okay but yeah nicole you have you
have the ability with this 50 000 to be
able you guys can buy some furniture
take a trip you're okay so just take a
breath
you have permission to do it you can do
it absolutely thanks for the call
thanks for your husband's service by the
way yes thank him for his service that's
incredible
ashley joins us up next in kansas city
ashley welcome to the ramsay show
hi
um i just wanted to say really quick i
love rachel i love your instagram reels
i love your weekly q a so i really
appreciate it thanks that's awesome
but uh i have a question so
um
me and my husband we've kind of been
daveish because you know he was at least
you know willing to start paying off the
debt with me and we didn't have too much
so we only had 15 000 but his main
sticking point was
that we had to keep our retirement at 15
um so but now i feel like that's slowing
us down when we're in baby step three
because we're done with baby step two
but we're right at the end of baby step
three
um so we'll have our fully funded
emergency fund of 12 000 um next month
awesome nice
but i feel like it's going to slow us
down now um to save for our down payment
on our house so i was wondering if you
guys had
to save that 20
um so we want to save around 30 to 40
000.
yeah that's awesome it's going to take
us about three years to do that okay if
we keep doing the 15 and that probably
maybe take us
two i mean if we kind of really get
after it maybe
um you know a little less than two years
if we uh and that's if you continue
investing at fifteen percent
yeah if we continue investing at fifteen
percent it's gonna take more around
three years but uh you're saving a year
if we pause investing yeah
yeah how how
urgent are you guys in in buying
something in the next two years well we
have a two bedroom house and we have
three kids so um
yeah the urgency is high the urgency is
highest i mean for me it's high um but
you know um he feels like we're not
going to have he feels like we're we're
only going to have like 1 million
um if if we stop saving and
he thinks we need more like three to
five million because of inflation we're
30 and 31. wow you guys got another 30
years of your career you're telling me
you're only going to have a million
dollars after investing for 30. he's
always the he's always the warrior so
well there it is i'm trying to make him
happy so ashley number one amazing job
you guys have killed it and i mean it's
just it's phenomenal the progress you
guys have made so obviously you're doing
something right i know you're you're
funding your retirement when you know i
get all that but
you're making the progress you guys are
doing it so
what it sounds like for him is he needs
facts so for you to say gosh i just feel
like we're gonna be okay
for him he has numbers so i would run
ashley some scenarios with an investing
calculator you can just go to ramsey
solutions.com we have them there
and run and say hey if we pause
retirement for 18 months to save up for
a down payment
here's where we're going to be at 65.
and then remember your income is going
to go up ashley you're not going to stay
stagnant for 30 years you guys are going
to be making more money
as you get great at your career so
factor that in and run some fun
scenarios give them one two three
scenario and show them you guys are
gonna be okay you're gonna be okay but i
appreciate his worry
but he needs some facts and logic good
points
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast joined
today by rachel cruz host of the rachel
cruz show you can find all of those
shows on the ramsey network or wherever
you listen to podcasts and on youtube
olivia joins us next she's in houston
texas olivia welcome to the show
hello hello thank you for having me
absolutely how can rachel and i help
all right my question is um we recently
me and my husband open up a
company
and he stopped working i do part-time
our question is how do we hide off of
our of our business profit like we it's
a first business we are so used to
tithing every
paycheck and now it's a little bit
confusing for us it means how do we go
about
tagging
from our business
yeah i mean it's a it's a great question
olivia and i love your heart in it and i
always say with this kind of these kind
of questions that there's
i don't like having like a major
legalistic
approach to it so i think you can never
go wrong with being overly generous so
if you skew the way of going overly
generous i don't think you can go wrong
there at all
uh
and then i would say on the other end i
i would still feel comfortable that
whatever your take-home pay is that's
what you guys
uh tithe on or for people that make a
salary if it's the net you know or
however they look at it but
i don't know if it's
necessary to tithe on the profits of the
business i would just do what your
taxable income is yeah what your
take-home pay is from the business
well
at the moment my husband's not really um
getting paid yet
and why is that
well
but we don't know how to go about it yet
so
that's the thing i mean there is money
there the company is making money but um
but he's not paying him
that's correct
hmm is this y'all's business together
yes okay so where's the money going
what's there it's fair the bank i guess
it's there i mean since i'm i am working
but i mean he he honestly has been
saying i need to start getting paid i
need to start getting paid but i
is he is he working in the business
though
that is correct he is working that's
what he's doing full time yes okay yeah
so he should but he's not paying him he
should pay himself he should pay himself
for the work how are you guys paying
your bills
uh well i do have a part-time
as well so that's how we're doing we
we're i mean we our only bills is our
light our water
and i guess our gas for a car and
insurance okay what kind of job what
kind of business is this
uh this is a field technician he does uh
calibrations for the water plants okay
and do you guys have any debt
no no and you oh you don't have a
mortgage
no
dang okay that's so great so how um
yeah your part-time income is what's
paying all the bills and then the
business income is just going to the
bank and just sitting there and
accounting is going to the bank and of
course paying i guess the the business
expenses side
correct okay well you've got to start
drawing something on this business it's
got to create an income for it to be
worth your time do you guys have
investments and stuff olivia like are
you guys have retirement set up and all
of that
not yet okay yet
i'm just trying to get a picture of
where you guys are financially so you
have zero debt no mortgage do you have
cash saved in the bank for an emergency
fund
we do yeah okay so you have that all
covered uh but you do not have any
retirement
no ma'am okay how old are you two
we are i am 36 he's 37. okay okay
so we still got time here do you guys
have employees like is this a big
business
just one just one okay okay
so yeah i mean if i were you guys i'd
run market rate on what he would be
worth out in the marketplace and you
guys look and say hey this is what
you're worth and let's pay this but but
then maybe you do say too olivia like
hey we have no bills we have no debts
we're just like basically living off our
essentials so we don't we may not need
i'm just making up a number here but say
it's a hundred grand
and you're like y'all may not need that
to live off of maybe y'all are
comfortable with 70 i'm taking home 70.
so that's 30 extra that you can look at
and say hey maybe we invest extra
um to maybe you know in an extra mutual
fund maybe we take some of that and
enjoy life and go on a trip or if you
need to upgrade a car
um so it's not a requirement that you
guys take out what market rate is but i
would at least run those numbers just to
know
hey here's how much it is and if he
wants and you guys have that
conversation because he may say no i
work my butt off and we could have a
hundred grand that i make a year
that's how i would feel and i'm like
yeah pay me a hundred grand if i'm worth
that or whatever whatever though if i'm
putting the work in i want to feel the
results of that
yes
i guess this past month just started
telling me exactly what you're saying
yeah i want to see my part too yes for
sure for sure and then you guys as a
couple decide hey
here's what we're going to bring in
here's what we really need to live off
of and then all this other stuff we can
maybe give generously we can spend some
we can invest some and yeah you guys get
to decide that's the beauty about owning
your own business is you kind of have
this flexibility to kind of figure out
hey what do we need um in our family
financially what's it bringing in what's
what's being responsible and mature
you're not going to be obviously using
your
company as like a bank and making more
than what you should but running those
numbers and kind of just getting an idea
i think would be really smart but great
job olivia you guys are you guys are
doing awesome though yeah great work
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from amanda in wisconsin
while we're while you're rebuilding your
emergency fund would you recommend
pausing your investments and only paying
minimum towards your mortgage i'm 28 and
earn 48 thousand dollars net and i'm on
baby step six i had to dip into my
emergency fund for the first time to
replace my furnace in a tune of four
thousand dollars if i continue investing
and pay off my home at my current rate
it will take me eight months to replace
the four thousand dollars versus three
months
if i pause investing and paying extra on
the mortgage
interesting question
yeah i mean it's an eight-month swing so
in my opinion i think you're fine
continuing it and letting it take eight
months first three so there's five
months that she's losing yeah five
months that surely if it was five years
i would say pause everything and restock
but if it's five
months i don't even know if i'd go
through the through the work of pausing
everything through your agent
all of that she's 28. she's got plenty
of time to keep investing so it's not
going to break her retirement and if
she's able to build wealth if she pauses
what i would say split the difference
continue investing but maybe pause the
extra mortgage payments there you go
until it's built back up and kind of
dangle that as a carrot to go i really
want to get back to paying off that
house early so i want to hustle and get
this emergency fund back and if all of
her emergency fund was drained
i would yeah i would pause it all just
to get some cash in but if it's four
thousand dollars out of it yeah we don't
know what her full emergency fund is but
i'm assuming here that 4 000 is not a
fully funded emergency fund for any
person no no i would think she has more
in there so
is it here am i lazy just to be like i
don't know if i want to go through the
effort i'm not going to answer the
question
i'm not going to answer that rachel this
is a trap i'm not going to say if you're
lazy or not
but no i think there's no right or wrong
hard and fast rule i don't think they're
especially at 28 this is a not a huge
amount of money
but i don't know in the time frame i
would pause the extra mortgage payments
that's my take okay i like that keep
investing pause the mortgage payments
and use that to fuel you to get this
thing built back up so you can get
because i can tell she's she wants to do
this thing i think yeah amanda either
way i think you're gonna be okay but i i
would george i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
your answer
ding ding ding remember this moment
america continue retirement
investing but yeah pause the extra on
the on the mortgage yeah that's good
george this is good stuff man you should
do this for a living i'll think about it
well rachel i want to shout out before
we go to break here that we had a
monstrous amazing viral instagram reel
that we posted about chick-fil-a so i
want to encourage america to go check
that out we did george you can go to
rachel cruz on instagram george campbell
on instagram that's camel with a k you
need some chick-fil-a hacks
we had them i mean two dollars rachel to
get a sandwich i'm just going to leave
maybe it'll maybe it'll go into other
the the the the pairing of george and
rachel maybe four people will probably
go check that check out that reel but
there's some good money-saving hacks
there and some good banter back and
forth that's great as we tend to do it's
great we gotta have a good time always
always always we'll be back soon give us
a call triple eight eight two five five
two two five you are listening to the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 12
no one can be established through
wickedness but the righteous cannot be
uprooted
stephen covey said there are three
constants in life chains
choice
and principles
i like that change choice and principles
good stuff
choice
and principles nailed it that's good
that means change will always happen
yeah that's right and choices will
always happen and principles but you
always want to keep them
your principles thank you for unpacking
this very helpful to me these these
quotes and stuff they always talk about
our team pulls them and it's all i
always learn something new a lot of
depth that's great shawn is joining us
up next in phoenix arizona sean welcome
to the show
hey guys i just had a quick question to
ask you guys and just wanted to get your
input all right um
yeah so my wife and i we own a condo and
with the housing you know market
how insane it is right now
uh we kind of have a situation where i
want to sell so that we could pay off
the rest of my wife's law school debt
um but ever since we've been living here
she really likes like
i keep it sorry
she wants to sell
so you want to sell it to pay off her
debt and what does she want correct
she wants to keep it um now we we came
to an agreement if a house keeps going
up and uh in inequity
to a certain point that she would want
to settle
okay how much debt is this
uh 90 000 is left on her law school 90
000 how much do you guys make a year
uh 160 000 household income 116 how much
could you get for the condo
uh
like what what what what's our end price
after everything yeah sorry yeah yeah of
what you owe on a number what would you
net
um around 170 000. 170
000.
i mean and the total debt you guys have
is the 90k of law school debt
correct just a 90k left
i mean i don't think you have to sell
this i don't think you do either i think
you guys can really live like you're
back in college
for a year or two and pay off this 90
and keep the condo
yeah that's the other options we could
pay off in about
over just over a year if we just really
pay off the go hard on that yeah
i would do that it's going to be hard
sean because i know kind of in a weird
way the easy thing would be like sell it
make a big profit write a check there's
nothing wrong with selling it and you
know just getting out of debt tomorrow
but i also don't think it's a dire
situation where i go dude you're on fire
you need to sell this thing you guys
have an amazing income and we say if you
can get out of debt in 18 to 24 months
then keep the condo then keep the car
it's okay
so that's my take uh but i would say
split the difference if you're saying i
want to sell this together that faster
get creative and talk to your wife and
go hey what could we do to make this
process happen even faster than one year
can you work overtime what if i got the
side hustle what if we could cut these
expenses and we got on a bare bones
budget for a year like rachel said in
order to speed up this process and
sacrifice for a shorter period of time
yeah because do you guys i mean do you
all like the condos i mean she obviously
loves it because she don't want to sell
it so is it a place that you're like no
we could be in here for another four or
five years
absolutely we both like the condo um the
reason why we bought it we bought it
about two years ago before the huge jump
in the housing market yeah
was because we had a good down payment
for it and we bought it for two reasons
one to lock in the rent crisis because
you know the mortgage doesn't go up but
prices do
and two to eventually sell it
and collect the equity and then that way
we could buy a different a different
gotcha yeah and so so that's why i kind
of want to sell because it's gotten up
so much in equity that with everything
going on in the economy
i do think there's going to be a slur
churn in the housing market for a couple
of years and i just want to get debt
free keep saving money and take
advantage of that yeah then sean what
happens is you sell it and you gotta go
turn around and either buy something
that's super expensive it's the top of
the market or you're gonna rent
super expensive because the top of the
market and so i know that it feels like
a good move to sell right now but you're
stuck in a corner at that point and so
i'm good with keeping this condo paying
off the debt yeah and then over time you
can save up and upgrade if you want to
later and the other i mean or the other
option is too sean
if you guys weren't happy with the con
that's why i asked where he's like no
we're wanting to upgrade soon
if that was in the near future in the
next 24 months then you could then
sell pay off the debt have 80 grand put
down
uh on a new place if you guys wanted to
buy high i mean it's you know it's kind
of yeah it's whatever you want to do but
i would say if you guys want to stay put
and you're comfortable staying put for
the next couple years
so don't worry about this market right
now houses will always go up in value
over a long period of time so great
questions thanks for the question man
chris is joining us up next in miami
florida chris welcome to the show
hey how's it going guys great what's up
with you
right so
essentially i i'd like to figure out a
way to
get moved out of my family's place and
move into my own spot and also
i get my girlfriend to move in with me
as well
pretty much
okay how long have you guys been dating
coming up on a year in about a week
actually chris why don't you why don't
you propose
um i'm still a full-time student and i'm
still living with family so
i don't feel like that's the smart
decision as of right now
so why are you wanting to move out
well so
it's kind of it's a little bit more
complicated so she we live uh we're
doing kind of a long distance
relationship i live in miami she lives
with my family in new york
um
and she lives with your family
my family yeah with other with family in
new york oh okay okay
right um and she's uh
just graduated with her associates and
she's doing uh a year of working because
she's not like on a full i guess she's
not a us citizen so she's working for a
year so she can get some money
and um after that she's gonna finish and
do her bachelor's degree but um i'm down
here in miami living with some other
family and i just feel like it's time
for me to get my own place and uh
like just
i don't feel like i'm being challenged
enough like i feel it's too easy
living with family and it you know how
much do you make of your christmas
um so i'm still a full-time student as
well maybe about
starting 2022 i've been making maybe
five to six grand a month
okay you're saying next year you'll be
making five six grand a month no that's
uh as of this year as of 2022 i've been
making about five to six years right
yeah
while doing school full-time
full-time students how much is possible
next week yeah how are you doing that
i'm just curious i work from home my
schedule really it works
wonders with me i'm a full-time student
online and i work from a sales job from
home online awesome chris great job yeah
i'm impressed um and how are you are you
how old are you
23 23 okay very cool
um so yeah chris i mean i think
kind of having your own dignity is what
it's sounding like of like i have the
ability to do this i mean you make you
know 70 grand it's awesome you're making
a great so yeah i mean i'm totally
comfortable with you you know creating a
budget and saying hey how much can i
spend on rent what's food going to look
like i mean go ahead and list out and
make a mock budget of what it would look
like for you to live on your own
and i think that's a great idea um and i
think that'd be awesome to make that
step uh i'm not a fan of living together
before you're married
uh so i would bring you know if she
wants to come down and rent a place next
to you or stay up in new york where you
are i mean the long-distance
relationship is kind of tough um i
understand that so
uh i mean if she wants to come down to
miami i think that's awesome but also i
would be like hey if you're willing to
move in with someone
i think it's time to be thinking about
put a ring on it i mean
i mean the only thing that stopped and
we just i'm i'm not comfortable
comfortable in my like
financially like i don't feel like i'm
stable where i've reached where i wanted
to because i'm again i
i plan on going to law school and i'm
only just at my associates right now so
i see like a law
like a long uh
progress between where i'm at now and
then and it just doesn't seem
like
yeah like a benefit to mary i
sure i hear you i would just say yeah
and i'm not for i'm not pushing you to
get married i would just say if it's uh
you
people are married in law school all the
time so it's totally doable so you can
you can get that route but again i'm not
pushing you to be like you you need to
you need to marry her but i would make
life decisions to set you up well for
the future and
we've just seen time and time again and
studies show that the divorce rate goes
up when you live together before you're
married i think there's a more
yeah there's just an element there to
keep things separate so i would continue
to do that chris and you're gonna be
able to cash flow law school because
you're making a great income you're
doing awesome chris so great job but
yeah graduate college and
living on your own it's impressive that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to rachel cruz my
co-host all the folks in the booth
austin will james andrew you name it
they're there and you america thank you
so much for listening until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you